a fifth woman is now coming forward with
allegations against US Senate candidate
judge Roy Moore during a news conference
today the woman accused judge Moore of
sexually assaulting her back in the
1970s when she was 16 years old and he
of course was 32 in his 30s now judge
Moore remains defiant and is denying
these new allegations amid growing calls
for him to withdraw from this special
election race as we've been saying these
allegations of beyond disturbing and we
understand why these women may be waited
so long before speaking out the bottom
line is what is the truth how do we find
the truth we're going into all of that
but first tonight conservatives voices
in this country at this hour face a
clear and present danger by millionaires
and billionaires funding the group
called Media Matters for America they
are the number one auntie free speech
the number one Pro censorship group in
this country they are at it again and
they are trying to silence the voice of
this program shut down all conservative
voices tonight a special Hannity
investigation we will expose this
liberal fascism that's tonight big
breaking news opening monologue alright
so I begin tonight with a special thank
you to all of you
I am beyond humbled by all of you our
viewers my radio listeners for the
support you showed me this weekend
it's unbelievable very humbling you were
the ones that made this show number one
in cable news last month we so greatly
appreciate it the bottom line is we
can't do this without your support we
work hard every day to give you news and
information you won't get elsewhere also
a very important message tonight I'll
explain please stop smashing your Keurig
coffee machines I'm going to explain how
this company was totally exploited they
are actually a victim in all of this
now Keurig was successfully targeted and
preyed upon by the most anti free-speech
Pro censorship group in the United
States today it is a group that is
bought and paid for by friends and
supporters of the Clintons and as you
may have seen the radical leftist group
media
Matters for America they launched yet
another smear campaign against me to try
to get me thrown off the air and get rid
of all my advertisers but just like the
numerous other attempts it's not working
thanks in large part to all of you and
for reacting the way you did this
weekend now before I explain how this
all went down I want to let you know
exactly who we're dealing with now
conservative voices in this country for
years we have been facing a clear and
present danger this is an unprecedented
act that is happening in this country
and it has to do with people right now
if you support this president if you are
conservative if you simply refuse to
parent like I do the Democratic talking
points like everybody else and the
left-wing destroy Trump mainstream media
your target anyone who dares to speak
out anyone that dares to tell the truth
about President Trump and what he's
accomplishing what he wants to
accomplish is a target and leftist and
this group want to shut down our voices
now this radical leftist group Media
Matters for America they have been and
continue to lead this effort they've
been doing this for years this
organization is funded by the likes of
George Soros and other leftist
millionaires and billionaires most of
them we don't even know they want
censorship in America they literally are
paying an army of people to listen to
every conservative show in the country
every single day every thought every
word every sentence on the airways then
they purposely twist lie distort
propagandize and weaponize whatever is
said what other other people say because
they want to silence every conservative
voice in the country this is a dangerous
time they have been doing this somewhat
successfully for years and now it's only
getting worse it is straight out of the
alinsky playbook isolate target destroy
one person at a time
it is the very definition of what I call
liberal fascism and just for a second I
want you to imagine this imagine if
they're successful ok people like me
Rush Limbaugh Mark Levin Laura Ingraham
Tucker Carlson Glenn Beck judge Jeanine
Pirro and everybody on Fox the entire
Fox News network is
in their perfect world the voices of the
people I just listed would be stifled
and stopped and you wouldn't be allowed
to hear their voices in their world
there would be no fox news channel in
their world there would be no dissent no
difference of opinion no free exchange
of ideas there would be just one
singular voice to reflect their radical
left-wing worldview it's how dangerous
it is Media Matters and they're paid
PACA hitmen they're hired guns they want
to shred America's Constitution as it's
currently configured and they want their
leftist ideology to be the law of the
land they do not believe in freedom of
speech now as for the incident with
Keurig coffee this weekend I want to
once again thank all of you for your
support it blew me away but for now
please please stop destroying your
coffee machines as I've been saying
Keurig they are a victim in this they
were attacked they were bombarded by the
phony fake moral outrage machine that is
Media Matters and they're highly
effective well financed targeting
machine they use all sorts of evil
tactics they use bot programming they
scare companies into overreacting and
that is exactly sadly what happened with
Keurig this weekend meteor matters well
they did what they always do and guess
what an employee for Keurig who works in
social media who's not used to dealing
with these extreme tactics sadly took
the bait and capitulated to the pressure
now the CEO to his credit of Keurig has
since apologized to all of his employees
today for taking sides in an email that
was obtained by the Washington Post it
reads in part this the fact is our
consumer demographics match well with
live news programming which is why we
advertise on nearly all cable news
channels ranging from MSNBC to Fox News
to see and then all of which will
continue however given the dynamic
nature of news we always need to
evaluate that programming environment on
a real-time basis and it continues the
decision to publicly communicate our
programming decision via our Twitter
account
was highly unusual this gave the
appearance of taking sides in an
emotionally-charged debate that
escalated on twitter and beyond over the
weekend which was not our intent I want
you to know the decision to communicate
our short-term media actions on Twitter
was done outside a company protocols
clearly this is an unacceptable
situation that requires an overhaul of
our issues response and external
communications policies and the
introduction of safeguards to ensure
this never happens again
our company and brand and reputations
are too valuable to put at risk in this
matter I'm gonna say tonight I believe
the CEO I believe is sincerity here and
guess what conservatives drink coffee
liberals drink coffee
libertarians drink coffee socialists
drink coffee drink coffe everyone drinks
coffee and he advertises on all news
networks this should be non political as
of now today before this ever happened
this weekend I have five Keurig machines
five of them I have never supported a
boycott in my life because I know what
they're about they're about censorship
and by the way I'm not going to start
tonight I am the strongest supporter of
freedom of speech on this program over
the years you've always heard me say I
don't like Bill Maher I don't I don't
even like them a little bit or Stephen
Colbert I don't like what they say but
guess what you ultimately have the power
turn the channel guess what you could
not watch them you don't have to listen
to any radio show watch any TV show you
don't want to watch but don't attack
their advertisers as a way to silence
what they're trying to say and what
keurig did was a mistake and the CEO
admitted it now this weekend I must
admit it was disheartening to learn that
Keurig that literally it was sucked in
by this machine known as Media Matters
but you our viewers unbeknownst to me
you fought back so tonight now please
I'm calling for a ceasefire here I
humbly appreciate your support but I'm
asking you to not smash your Keurig and
I must admit these videos this weekend I
watched and I laughed
they are hysterical what's this
this is what I think of you carry all of
that was done to support my ability to
continue to do this show every night
I am beyond humbled now I as I said I
own five cure eggs please stop
destroying yours and by the way for the
people who did later this week I have a
big announcement I will be giving away
500 coffee makers
now I'll decide on the brand that I'll
be giving away in the coming days based
on how things unfold now the reason that
Media Matters exploited Keurig was in my
response to my coverage of the
accusations against judge Roy Moore and
my radio interview that we did with them
on Friday we also played Friday night
right here on this program now on that
radio show on Thursday I had mentioned
Thursday Media Matters latched on to one
thing I said about the judge Roy Moore
allegations in almost three hours of
talking about the allegations and at one
point for one split second there was
slight ambiguity that I immediately
cleared up predictably Media Matters
ignored the other two plus hours of
programming sprung into action proceeded
to purposely twist to store my comments
then spread lies all over social media
about what I said now before I play for
you what I said it's important to
understand who we're dealing with here
who is medium matters well a guy by the
name of Angelo Karras Sony he is the
president of Media Matters for America
now his anti free speech is Pro
censorship group is trying to silence
every conservative voice in this country
now there's a website dedicated look at
it right there
- exposing who is
this guy that wants to silence every
conservative voice who is Angelo karo
Sony well there's a website you can look
it up for yourself it's called Angelo
karo Sony com you can see it up on your
screen it is full of vile vicious
comments that he even admits that he
made if you look at his Twitter account
now we have not independently verified
the website but I encourage you to check
it out for yourself let's put it this
way if any conservative made the remarks
that are found on that website
Angelo Kara Sony com well Angela Kara
Sony would be calling for a boycott of
himself check it out and I want to be
crystal clear that guy have been this
entire time when it comes to judge Roy
Moore if the allegations these serious
allegations against him are true as I
have been saying again and again and
again and again it is beyond disgusting
it is beyond reprehensible I said that
to judge Moore directly when I
interviewed him on Friday and like I've
been saying I completely understand I am
completely sympathetic to why women wait
to tell their stories of sexual
harassment people that have genuinely
been traumatized experienced evil
experience the most painful thing anyone
could ever think of and with all of that
in mind here's just some of what I was
saying about judge Moore on radio
Thursday that medium matters never want
you to listen to listen to this we all
find any allegation of abuse of women
repugnant all of us and unacceptable
this is a very hard topic because for a
lot of reasons I can understand women
that don't speak I find it repugnant
anybody that abuses a woman this way
absolutely repugnant because we all hate
anybody that would abuse any woman
because it's so offensive that this is
such a horrific act of evil violence and
so traumatizes people that they live in
fear they live in fear of you know a
howl that they don't want people to know
this horrible thing happened to them so
they bottle it up they keep it up inside
and then fear that they're not going to
be believed fear that there
gonna be blamed fear you know I mean I
think there's legitimate reasons why you
know and personal reasons why women wait
and here's what I said this is the first
night of coverage on TV that very night
that they're using to distort smear
slander boycott and get me fired what's
this
a woman is alleging to the Washington
Post that back in 1979 when she was 14
years old she had a sexual encounter
actually two of them would then 32 year
old Roy Moore three other women are also
accusing Moore of sexual misconduct back
to the 1970s while they were teenagers
in the case of judge Moore if it's true
he should step aside and leave the
Senate race everyone would agree
everybody a 32 year old man pursuing a
fourteen year old girl is disgusting
that is something we should all agree on
this should transcend politics
these are very serious allegations of
course they have to be investigated to
the full extent you understand what I'm
saying is it any wonder groups like
Media Matters they never shared any of
what I said they took at a context
twisted diced and spliced all four
political partisan reasons it's because
they would rather be take out of context
to smear slander and shut me up they've
tried this for many years against many
conservatives then on Friday I actually
was the only one that interviewed judge
Roy Moore about the allegations and just
like I said it is important to listen to
all sides before we rush to judgment I
believe in the presumption of innocence
of every single American because time
and again we have seen the media and
others like President Obama he's a great
example rush to judgment and get big
issues completely wrong look at the Duke
Lacrosse case look at the Cambridge
police look at Ferguson Missouri hands
up don't shoot Trayvon Martin George
Zimmerman and I learned this with
Richard Jewell in Atlanta media rushes
to judgment damages and destroys
people's lives and I learned my lesson a
long time ago wait until all the facts
come out do my research talk to the
people involved before I make a decision
that to me is fundamentally fair I did
this with all the Bill Clinton's
accusers I sat down with them I looked
them in the eye I am
than what happened they told their
stories and on Friday I did exactly the
same thing with judge Roy Moore I went
point by point through the allegations
every single allegation against him I
challenged him on every single one and I
let him respond because this is too
serious to play games with watch this
listen to this would it be unusual for
you as a 32 year old guy to have dated a
woman as young as 17 now be a what 15
year difference or a girl 18 do you
remember dating girls that young at that
time know if any Senate candidate who
was 32 at the time had done this to a 14
year old girl to me it's disgusting to
me it would be despicable to me that is
a predator would you agree with me no
such person who ever does that should
ever be in the United States Senate of
course let's go back to it one more
question because I didn't understand
this if you're 32 and you do date again
this is different 17 or 18 year old
that's a pretty big gap for a pretty
young girl is that something you did
when you are dating not I'm not talking
about the 14 year old in that specific
allegation would it be normal behavior
back in those days for you to date a
girl that's 17 or 18 no if my daughter
is 17 my daughter 16 years old if she's
17 or 18 I don't want her dating a 32
year old and you can say unequivocally
you never dated anybody that was in
their late teens like that when you were
32 my customary behavior yes right in
other words you don't recall ever dating
any girl that young when you were that
old no and you think that's
inappropriate to that's what you're
saying
I asked every question I got widespread
praise too serious a topic and then on
TV again not covered by this leftist
group that is the number one censorship
group in the country then on Friday
night I said
this as I said last night
these are very serious accusations and
if they are true more should leave that
Senate race if now everyone agrees a 32
year old man pursuing a 14 year old girl
is despicable and beyond disgusting
alright what I said there is exactly
right
these are very serious allegations
against judge Roy Moore they need to be
handled I treated that way which is
exactly what I did and unlike many in
the liberal mainstream media we actually
care about truth I said that every day
we care about facts we care about
getting it right and that's what I was
trying to find out before reaching a
conclusion many rush to judgment in the
media and elsewhere in fact and Media
Matters will never tell you this liberal
members of the media actually praised my
interview with judge Moore look at some
of the tweets fair is fair Hannity is
not letting Moore off the hook here at
Sean Hannity kentuc inducting a
meticulous tough interview with Roy
Moore who's coming across as
unconvincing and dismissive of very
serious allegations hannity is actually
doing a pretty effective job of making
more address specific allegations in the
Washington Post piece had doubts but at
Sean Hannity not doing a bad job
pressing more on allegations now in the
media the left-wing media they don't
like me says I did a good job okay it's
probably a grand slam it's probably
winning the Stanley Cup but Media
Matters never reported those facts what
I said this is so important if you want
conservative voices to remain it shows
you how low they go to silence a
conservative voices of the atmosphere
that we work in every conservative on
radio and television this is so
important this is my big takeaway from
tonight's monologue unlike a lot of the
sheep and the destroyed Trump mainstream
media we hear on this program
I am open about my support of the
president much of his agenda we're
willing to give him a fair shake
unlike many in the media on this show we
don't rush to judgment without all the
facts and I will never rush the judgment
and because I believe and I will never
apologize for believing in the
presumption of innocence
the allegations against judge Roy Moore
are very serious
we need truth they need to be
investigated the voters in Alabama
deserve the truth before they decide who
to cast their ballots for and as I said
Friday if that means moving back the
election then so be it whatever it takes
and if these allegations are true judge
Moore needs to step aside also one more
thing a day of reckoning it's now headed
in the clintons direction because all of
their shenanigans their abuse of women
in the case of Bill Clinton over the
years are taking money from countries
that abuse women kill gays and lesbians
and persecute Christians and Jews now
things you see are changing in the
country and all of those that made
excuses and cover it up for the Clinton
all these Clintons all these years they
will have to answer some serious
questions in the days to come